how are you feeling about the bitcoin
market where we are coming into the end
of the year has anything changed
nothing's changed um i mean i think the
timeline is a little bit delayed like
compared to what a lot of people thought
in the fall
at the beginning of q4 um
you know a lot of people were kind of
expecting to see to see higher prices
than than today and for you know
all-time highs to be excuse me for
all-time highs to continue to be to be
made here but in terms of the thesis in
terms of what bitcoin is and and you
know where we're going with this whole
thing nothing has changed i think you
know that's what we're going to dig into
a little bit today
all right so when we start looking at
some of the charts that we have here the
first that we're going to pull up is
this bitcoin store value medium of
exchange or unit of account and you just
have uh what looks like the price
pulled up in terms of uh
uh over the years what exactly are you
showing here
yeah so this is more of just like a kind
of a title slide i saw some some of the
jack discourse last night um in the next
slide it kind of it was a question that
says do you think the that bitcoin will
replace the us dollar um and you know
there's definitely a lot of debate
bitcoin is digital gold or bitcoin is
going to displace a dollar or bitcoin uh
to some people is a ponzi scheme um but
really i think uh you know we're going
to use some some metrics today and look
at some charts and kind of break down
what what i believe and i think what a
lot of people
that are bitcoin proponents believe is
that bitcoin is actively becoming or is
already all three um and then the data
kind of shows that
all right so if we start with uh the
first chart we've got the issuance rate
and the circulating supply and market
cap all overlaid on each other what
exactly is this showing yeah so this is
kind of supporting the store of value
argument right so you hear a lot of
people um increasingly over the last
couple years this has been an accepted
kind of proposition bitcoin is digital
gold it's a digital store of value
and while that was controversial for a
long time
a lot of the skeptics um you know
besides a few have come to accept that
you know bitcoin is a store of value and
you know in the 21st century um
especially after the kind of covid
madness and all of the trillions of
dollars of stimulus bitcoin is a store
of value and so you know it's the one
thing we know that it has a hard cap is
absolutely scarce in the world uh this
issuance rate or inflation rate um is
programmatically trending to towards
zero over time the blue line that's
actually in log scale so uh in linear
and linear scale it looks like the
issuance rate is already basically at
zero
um and the market uh the market cap is
really just a testament of people around
the world allocating you know resources
and capital to this asset class because
of its monetary assurances and so the
store value argument is stronger than
ever but you know i don't think it stops
there and that's when uh you know the
discourse gets a little more interesting
got it and so really what this is
showing is as that issuance rate goes
down or some people could think that it
almost says like an inflation rate uh
the circulating supply goes up right uh
because we're getting more and more uh
bitcoin just at a slower pace uh but the
market cap has continued to grow at the
exact same time as well which ends up
being uh uh kind of a what you would
expect if you've got a finite supply
asset with a disinflationary monetary
supply schedule uh an increasing demand
is you're going to continue to get the
price to go up even though there's a
little bit of bitcoin still coming into
the market uh the demand outpaces that
and that's where you get market cap
growth right
yeah exactly i mean it's pretty simple
it's how many dollars are going to exist
in 2030 or in 2100 right no one knows no
one knows really for any other asset
except bitcoin and and you know this
because you can run a full node on you
know an old laptop or you can verify the
supply on your smartphone and there's no
other technology yes there are other
crypto assets that are somewhat
transparent but the thing is that none
of the monetary policies of these other
assets or you know digital uh assets are
basically as uh tried and tested as
bitcoin and no one can change bitcoin um
and every protocol change that has
occurred has been um opt-in voluntary
it's a soft fork
there's there's no hard forks or changes
to the monetary policy of bitcoin you
know whereas other crypto protocols or
assets um or currencies if you want to
call them that have have done that
plenty of time so in terms of in terms
of absolute scarcity nothing in the
world
has or can compete with bitcoin